wait till I get to a Sal's story oh wait
do you see all the way oh wait
Sal's dad came here from Italy at age 14
right yeah yeah dropped out of high
school at age 15 went into the pizza
business mm-hmm in fact Sal's dad claims
he invented pizza toppings right yes and
the round pizza the round pizza and
pizza toppings yeah he no kidding he
invented the calzone
yes yeah it should I set this up to this
new regulation this is you know I've
said I think we've learned everything
about Sal that there is to know about
his marriage about his father about
everything yeah recently Sal learned he
has two sisters he never knew about like
how recently like just a couple of days
ago yeah pretty close yeah well we've
known that Sal has had siblings stepping
up let's read the stories right yeah
they're the third and fourth siblings
that have been discovered from outside
the family yes well as a special
Father's Day treat we have Sal's dad
live via satellite from his home if you
look over Robyn on the guest couch
monitor you'll be able to see south
[Music]
what I mean what do you say wait to see
this on me not gray-haired listen to
Mario Merola
you know them at all what can we say
we're shocked by the amount of sexual
activity without a rubber that you had
very much very much I find very sad I
pray for the forgiveness from all the
saints but I promise so that's all
there's definitely not a 396 or more
kids out there I stopped looking ok
alright and in so many children can even
track their names so many fathers day a
very busy day I have a sol Claudia
Patricio Sergio Barrera Gianna Gianna
Gianna Alessandro bolaño
Donna benissa Marco Marco liebe Biglia
Guevara Pavarotti Lamarr Brent cysteine
Fiorello Fiorina Fiorano Giancarlo Carlo
do you know all the kids names it's
unbelievable I'm shocked that you do I
know half I know what 200 don't feel any
remorse do you feel bad about what you
did but I hated these DNA websites I
find out who run the website I take a
loaf of bread and I beat the [ __ ] out of
a it's an italian sword huh you know
maybe I don't want to be radical here
but maybe you should get your balls
clipped
I mean it's outrageous right yeah you're
more active than a sperm donor but I
pray I prayed to the same so that my
wife forgive me I pray this Anthony st.
been easier and I'm a faithful man now
and no more sneak around I know you're a
good man now and let's put on this oh
hold on one second I get a phone call
you hold on yeah okay uh you know this
is a Tony I know I come by five o'clock
I tell my wife about a window it's okay
okay I got the money in that zone
sorry that's that's it a telemarketers I
keep going mr. Govan alley it sounded to
me like maybe you were up to your old
ways and shenanigans right after you
just cried to the whole family
I pray for forgiveness Aleut Li
absolutely well I hope you have a happy
Father's Day mr. Govan Ali of course
it'd be a great day my windows look very
dirty I gotta go get the Windex right
now go ahead okay oh one second the door
I get the door you go ahead yeah there
was hundreds of children when the door
opened you you claim those are not your
children a Jehovah Witness Jehovah
Witness oh my god you know don't you get
stressed out mr. Govan Ali with all of
these shenanigans that we just think you
want to come home on a Saturday put your
feet up and relax a trillion dollar in
the child support huh
two trillion dollars and I think about
you you were so successful in the
pizzeria business you invented pizza you
invented round pizza invented the
calzone you invented toppings you get no
credit right and you have nothing to
show for it except for that cardboard
house you live in
oh it's a beautiful house I live in a
bay shore I have all my pictures on the
wall I have on my favorite family
picture me and Sal at the pizza dear
when I beat him with the bread you took
a picture when you were beating salad
bread and you keep that on the wall to
remember that moment next to it the
invention I invite the toppings on the
pizza huh yes yes the pepperoni I
invented a sauce in bread yeah used to
just be the cheese it's called road
please around it used to be a triangle
triangle how you say triangle had three
sides sorry inside so I see you triangle
has how many sides seven said yeah
seven side by the way not only did you
invent pizza but I should mention you
invented beating your son over the head
with bread no one had really ever done
this or most people usually use their
hands or something oh it's a it's a you
know bottle how do you say innovate yeah
well personally you're very handsome man
I can see why all these women go through
sunglasses you got a full head of hair
you look great I'm a fuzzy no you know
yeah as you know that's what they say
handsome man in Italy right well the
govern alle name will live on for a
million years because of his baby you
have so many babies out there and it's
important that that name kid I have a
two kid in five 41 in a mess up equals
15 on a comeback road a lot of people
want to know and I mean with all
seriousness a lot of people end up just
why don't you put a robber on what is it
are you allergic to rubber Robert what
sort of a rubber is a birth control why
not use a birth control oh but simila
yeah but you know that's that's a bad
that the how you say feel like [ __ ] Oh
Fred you have father issues I mean this
house father take the cake or what well
I never got beaten with bread so I then
I think you got it over on me yeah you
worked in a pizza do you grow up Fred no
I do not oh are you sure I take it a
bread right now hit hard I gotta go the
window are very dirty I have to go get
the Windex okay go ahead
[Music]
Thank You mr. Govan Ali all right and on
that note happy Father's Day everybody
it's all good